bonjour et merci d'être avec nous ce
soir sur arte france quel bilan est ce
que vous tirez aujourd'hui de la
politique environnementale des manuels
macro est ce que c'est suffisant
alors non seulement la politique
environnementale menée par emmanuel
macron n'a pas été suffisante mais en
plus ça a été beaucoup de belles paroles
et très peu d'actes en vérité au bilan
d' emmanuel macron net notamment
l'autorisation donnée à total d'utiliser
de l'huile de palme à la mède on a le
retournage de veste sur l'interdiction
des néonicotinoïdes est utile il faut
that de nombreux autres décisions qui
pèsent à son actif comme les projets
montagne d'or et encore hier la
destruction des jardins partagés à
aubervilliers donc par rapport justement
à ces grandes déclarations on voit bien
que le bilan en matière de biodiversité
il est très mauvais en france et donc
nous allons beaucoup plus que juste
justement des grands discours politique
et on sait que malheureusement ces
congrès internationaux ce sont souvent
des belles paroles mais nous voulons des
chiffres nous voulons aussi des moyens
financiers et humains pour réellement
agir pour la biodiversité quels sont
selon vous les sujets les plus urgents
les mesures à prendre le plus rapidement
possible en matière environnementale
alors avec l'association wild guns nous
prenons un vrai changement de paradigme
c'est à dire que aujourd'hui nous
voulons une protection de la nature pour
elle même lui faire faire en sorte
d'avoir un nouveau droit qui protège les
droits de la nature comme sujet de droit
comme dépositaire de droits fondamentaux
c'est une campagne que nous menons et
nous organiserons du coup en off à côté
de l'iucn un événement d'une journée
entière qui s'appelle le forum pour les
droits des écosystèmes aquatiques à
marseille et qui parlera notamment de la
protection des glaciers qui sont c'est
en europe de la pollution des fleuves
des rivières est aussi des océans parce
que je le rappelle emmanuel macron à son
bilan il y a aussi la pollution aux
boues rouges au large de marseille et
des calanques il visitait quand même
tout à l'heure avec nicolas hulot pour
faire un joli saïfi mais aujourd'hui
c'est pas suffisant de faire des sales
fille il faut vraiment agir alors la
france accueille donc cette année le
congrès mondial de l'union
internationale pour la conservation de
la nature quel rôle la france doit jouer
selon vous au d'un point de vue mondial
sur ces questions environnementales
la france en fait et c'est outre-mer
notamment c'est une richesse incroyable
en termes de biodiversité
donc il faut agir aujourd'hui la
nombreuses associations qui se
mobilisent je suis par exemple la
marraine aussi d'une campagne lancée il
y a deux jours par on est prêt c'est un
collectif rassemblant des activistes une
campagne qui est centrée justement sur
la sixième extinction de masse et
notamment les animaux menacer en france
métropolitaine donc pendant plusieurs
semaines on est prêts donnera des clés
pour devenir des gardiens de la nature
et l'objectif c'est d'alerter justement
massivement de prendre conscience qu'il
se passe en france est d'apprendre à
serez émerveillé du vivant de participer
et de ré ensauvagé notamment en
soutenant des associations comme
l'espace et le centre athénas qui sur le
terrain elle protège sont engagés au
quotidien pour la défense de cette
biodiversité en danger
et mariama croire a donc annoncé la
tenue fin 2021 au début 2022 d'un sommet
one sens comment est ce que vous avez
accueilli cette annonce est ce que ça va
dans le bon sens
oui bien sûr ça va dans le bon sens mais
quels sont les engagements qui seront
tenues à la suite de ceux de cette
grande rencontre je le rappelle la
france malheureusement il n'a pas
beaucoup de leçons à donner
personnellement j'étais fortement engagé
en guyane française contre les forages
pétroliers qui ont mis à mal la
biodiversité les tortues les dauphins
les baleines qui viennent nidifier dans
les zones
maritime au large de la guyane encore
une fois emmanuel macron était déjà
ministre à cette époque et aujourd'hui
il ya énormément d'autres projets qui
continuent de polluer la méditerranée
qui est pleine de plastique mais aussi
de polluants lourds et donc la france
doit véritablement être irréprochable de
cette de ce point de vue là et donc il
faut absolument sortir de cette
politique des petits pas il faut aller
vers une politique des grands pas en
avant et c'est pour ça qu'avec
l'association wild guns nous demandons
la reconnaissance des droits de la
nature de l'océan mais aussi de tous les
écosystèmes aquatiques qui sont
aujourd'hui en danger du fait de la
pression des activités humaines or l'eau
potable va tenir dans les prochaines
années véritablement un enjeu majeur de
société de survie mais aussi de ce que
nous voulons sauvegarder en commun notre
héritage à tous donc c'est véritablement
l'enjeu du siècle à venir de sauvegarde
et justement ces écosystèmes aquatiques
et notamment l'océan ces sommets sur les
sur l'environnement permettent d'avancer
réellement on a le sentiment qu'il se
multiplient ces derniers mois ces
dernières années concrètement est-ce
qu'ils servent vraiment à quelque chose
où là encore comme vous le décrivez ce
sont surtout moyens de faire bonne
figure pour un bon nombre de
gouvernements
ce qui est sûr c'est que aujourd'hui la
société civile elle est mobilisée
d'ailleurs à marseille aujourd'hui il ya
de nombreuses manifestations
d'autres sont prévues tout le long
justement ce grand congrès pour
continuer à faire pression si les choses
avancent c'est grâce à la société civile
aujourd'hui qui est engagée pour
continuer à mettre la pression sur les
décideurs publics évidemment la plupart
des choses qui sont décidés dans ces
grands congrès elles sont le reflet de
ce que veulent notre société ça va pas
assez vite par sd loin ni la cité sidi
el al est prête elle est là et comme je
vous disais ça va en fait venir du bas
vers le haut donc il faut qu'on soit
tous mobilisés pour continuer à nous
faire entendre et faire avancer les
choses parce qu'effectivement
on sait se faire là ça ne va pas assez
vite si on ne leur fait pas comprendre
qu'il ya une urgence clair à agir nous
ne voulons pas nous retrouver dans le ce
bateau qui coule nous voulons reprendre
les rênes du navire et décider ensemble
de l'avenir que nous voulons construire
merci beaucoup d'avoir répondu à notre
invitation sur arte france marine calme
est présidente de l'association howells
légal france